Working in games is interesting because there are all kinds of things that go into programming a game. You know, there are lots and lots of different aspects. There are lots of, you're not just working in one place. Or at least if you're in a big studio, there are lots of different kinds of engineers who specialize in maybe different things. You know, there's to just run through a very small sample, there's specialization in, well, graphics is obviously one. And that subdivides. animation is sort of a separate subfield of that networking physics AI AI as it's called in games gameplay UI audio you know I could go on and on but there are lots of specializations available
在游戏行业工作很有意思，因为编程一部游戏需要涉及各种各样的事情。你知道的，有非常非常多的不同方面。有很多方面，你不仅是在一个地方工作。或者至少如果你在一个大工作室里，会有很多不同种类的工程师，他们可能专精于不同的事情。你知道的，仅仅列举一个非常小的样本，专精领域有，嗯，图形学显然是一个。而且这还可以细分。动画某种程度上是其中的一个独立子领域，网络、物理、AI（在游戏里通常就叫AI）、玩法、UI、音频，你知道的，我可以一直说下去，但有非常多的专业方向可供选择。
welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 296 recorded on July 22nd 2020s my name is Connor and today with my co-host Ben we chat about video games working in the video game industry and more Have things with you, Ben. Oh, you know. Same old, same old. It's summer. It's hot. I'm actually off work at the moment this week.
欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 296 期，录制于 2020 年 7 月 22 日。我是康纳，今天和我的联合主持本一起，我们聊聊电子游戏、游戏行业的工作以及更多内容。本，你最近怎么样？哦，你懂的。老样子，老样子。现在是夏天。天气很热。实际上我这周休假呢。
Spending some time with the family. Just doing summer things. We went to the local, like, play place to do all the mini golf and go-karting and bowling and stuff like that. Oh, that's fun. Are you a big mini-golf fan? I like mini-golf. it's fun. I wouldn't say I'm a big fan.
花点时间陪陪家人。就做一些夏日活动。我们去了当地那种游乐场，玩了迷你高尔夫、卡丁车、保龄球之类的地方。哦，那挺好玩的。你是个迷你高尔夫狂热粉丝吗？我挺喜欢迷你高尔夫的。这挺有趣的。我不会说我是个大粉丝。
I don't like do it every weekend. But I'm a good enough fan. I'll always do the mini golf. For some reason, I, you know, I'm not a big sports player, but I like the sports video games as well. There's something about sports video games that make them better than the actual sport,
我不会每个周末都去玩。但我算是一个合格的粉丝。只要有迷你高尔夫，我总是会去玩。不知为什么，你知道的，我不是个擅长运动的人，但我也很喜欢体育类电子游戏。体育类电子游戏总有某种魔力，让它们比实际的运动更好玩，
especially when it comes to golf. Interesting. Watching golf on TV? No, not for me. attending, even playing golf? I've played a bit of golf in my time, but no, it's a good walk spoiled. But golf video games are surprisingly
尤其是高尔夫球。有趣。在电视上看高尔夫球？不，对我来说不了。去现场看，甚至自己打高尔夫？我这辈子也打过一点高尔夫，但算了，这就是一次被毁掉的好散步。不过高尔夫电子游戏却出奇地
compelling. Which is your favorite? We golf? Back in the day? Well, let me tell you, the best golf video game ever made is Mario Golf on the Game Boy Color. But that is now quite old. The golf games are, there are a lot of golf games out there.
引人入胜。你最喜欢哪一款？我们打高尔夫吗？以前的时候？嗯，让我告诉你，有史以来最棒的高尔夫电子游戏是 Game Boy Color 上的《马力欧高尔夫》。但那现在已经相当老了。高尔夫游戏嘛，市面上有非常多的高尔夫游戏。
Everybody's golf is pretty good. I haven't played any of these. I'm going to have to find a way. I'm sure I can get some emulated to play a GameCube game, no? Yeah, yeah, or a Game Boy game even. Did I say GameCube? I meant to say, no, I said Game Boy color, I think. Okay.
《大众高尔夫》挺不错的。这些我都没玩过。我得想办法玩玩看。我确信我能搞到模拟器来玩 GameCube 的游戏，对吧？对，对，或者甚至 Game Boy 的游戏。我刚刚说的是 GameCube 吗？我本来想说，不，我说的是 Game Boy Color，我想是的。好吧。
Yeah. This is, I'm losing on my nerd cred, because I never had a Game Boy. I never had a Game Cube. So I just, I hear game and I just, my brain was like, eh, you know, one and the same, which I do know that they're different. One's purple, I think, classically. The GameCube was purple, yeah. Yeah, and then the Game Boy is, they come in a bunch of different colors.
对。这个，我正在失去我的书呆子信誉，因为我从来没有过 Game Boy。我从来没有过 Game Cube。所以我听到“游戏（game）”这个词，我的大脑就觉得，呃，你知道的，都一样。不过我确实知道它们是不同的。经典配色里有一个是紫色的吧。GameCube 是紫色的，对。对，然后 Game Boy 是，它们有各种不同的颜色。
I do know folks. I did see people on the playground. That had them, okay? I just never did. Well, I'm getting to the age where I don't know games these days. The only games I remember now are games from, let's say, 20 years ago and previous. I don't keep up with games very much these days. So, you know, with golf games, it's really about do you want, well, with a lot of sports games,
我确实知道的，伙计们。我确实在操场上看到过别人有，好吧？我只是从来没有过。嗯，我到了这个年纪，现在都不太懂游戏了。我现在还记得的游戏，都是大约 20 年前以及更早的游戏。现在我不太跟得上游戏的发展了。所以，你知道的，对于高尔夫游戏来说，这实际上取决于你是否想要，嗯，对于很多体育游戏来说，
is do you want hyper-realism? Sports games are pretty much the only games these days, I think, that are still pushing the realism aspect. games in general or like across all video games? I was talking last night to Ava about this and it's like, you know, the stage we're at with video games is almost like we've reached a plateau. I think, you know, it's been a thing for many years now that pushing realism is not really what games are about, right? The games that stand the test of time are the ones that,
就是你想要极致的真实感吗？我觉得体育游戏几乎是现在仅有的几个还在推崇真实感方面的游戏了。是指整体游戏还是所有电子游戏？昨晚我和艾娃谈过这个，情况就是，你知道的，我们目前所处的游戏阶段几乎就像是到达了一个平台期。我想，你知道的，多年来推动真实感已经不是游戏的核心所在了，对吧？经得起时间考验的游戏是那些，
not necessarily the ones that try to be high. hyper realistic in graphics or any other thing, but they have a proper direction. They have an art style. They have a, you know, a proper design. And for a while, you know, the games that were really pushing the cutting edge were things like the FPSs with their hyper focus on graphics. And I think the sports games, because the sports games do have this kind of hyper realism focus.
不一定是那些试图在图形或其他任何方面做到超逼真的游戏，而是它们有正确的发展方向。它们有艺术风格。它们有，你知道的，恰当的设计。有一段时间，你知道的，真正推动尖端技术的游戏是一些第一人称射击游戏，它们超级专注于图形。而我认为体育游戏，因为体育游戏确实有这种对极致真实感的专注。
And part of the way they succeed in that is because they are, you know, in many cases, and they can bring out new rosters and they can bring out incremental updates to realism, effectively. But even there, you know, going back to golf games, you know, this is something I was saying. The important thing about a sports game, I think, is not, in fact, the graphics, but, you know, how well it plays. Sort of sounds simple to say, right? But there's a lot that goes into the feel and the touch of sports games in whatever sports. which is why I say that, you know, Mario Golf on the Game Boy Color
它们之所以能取得部分成功，是因为它们，你知道的，在许多情况下，它们可以推出新的球员名单，并且它们可以对真实感进行渐进式的更新，实际上是这样的。但即便如此，你知道的，回到高尔夫游戏，你知道的，这是我一直说的。我认为，一款体育游戏最重要的其实不是图形，而是，你知道的，它玩起来手感如何。听起来很简单对吧？但在各种体育游戏的体感和手感背后，有很多门道，这也是为什么我说，你知道的，Game Boy Color 上的《马力欧高尔夫》
is one of the best golf games ever made. You know, you wouldn't think the Game Boy was capable, but the amount of feel they put into that game is pretty amazing. Well, this is awesome. We can have, like, a mini video games episode. Maybe we could do part one where we talk about just video games from a playing point of view,
是有史以来最好的高尔夫游戏之一。你知道的，你不会觉得 Game Boy 有这种能力，但他们塞进那款游戏里的手感简直太惊人了。哇，这太棒了。我们可以来一场像是一期迷你电子游戏的小节目。也许我们可以做第一部分，只从玩的角度来聊聊电子游戏，
but then also, too, I mean, I imagine most of our listeners know, but you worked in the games industry. About 23 years, yeah. Yeah, I worked for Electronic Arts. I worked for Blizzard, you know, so I worked for some... I didn't know you worked for EA. That's where I started. Well, I, you know, I worked at Bullfrog back in a day when they had been bought by EA.
但除此之外，我的意思是，我想我们的大多数听众都知道，你在游戏行业工作过。大约 23 年，对。对，我为艺电（Electronic Arts）工作过。我为暴雪工作过，你知道的，所以我为一些... 我不知道你在 EA 工作过。那是我开始的地方。嗯，我，你知道的，早年在 Bullfrog 工作过，当时它已经被 EA 收购了。
Oh, did you ever go to the Vancouver campus or Burnaby campus? I did. Yeah, I visited Vancouver, I think, once. Wow. That's crazy. Yeah, so, I mean, I imagine most of our listeners know EA, big sports brand, but they don't know, is that I got to tour that place three different times because very randomly, I went to the National Science Fair three times in high school and you represent BC at the national level because that's where I lived.
哦，你去过温哥华校区或本拿比校区吗？去过。是的，我想我参观过温哥华一次。哇。太疯狂了。对，所以，我的意思是，我想我们的大多数听众都知道 EA，一个大的体育品牌，但他们不知道的是，我曾经三次参观过那个地方，因为非常偶然的是，我在高中时三次参加了全国科学展，你代表 BC 省参加全国比赛，因为那就是我住的地方。
And as a thank you for representing BC, half a year later in October, because the fair would be in like May, they would fly, well, everyone would go to Vancouver. If you didn't happen to live in Vancouver, they would fly you there. They would set you up in a fancy hotel and then they like take you all these tech companies. Like, I think one of the companies they took us to one time was SAP. And I was like, why are they taking us here? But the highlight was always going to EA, because EA was like in terms of like corporations. It's like a little mini Disneyland because it's got outdoor courts and they would show,
作为代表 BC 省的谢意，半年后的 10 月份——因为展会在 5 月左右举行，他们会把——嗯，所有人都会去温哥华。如果你恰好不住在温哥华，他们会飞送你过去。他们会把你安排在豪华酒店里，然后带你参观所有这些科技公司。比如，我想他们有一次带我们去参观的公司之一是 SAP。当时我就想，为什么他们要带我们来这里？但重头戏总是去 EA，因为从公司的角度来看，EA 就像一个小型的迪士尼乐园，因为它有户外球场，他们会展示，
they would bring you by obviously the people that are testing games. Like that's their job. They like eight hours a day. They're just like. And then it's kind of funny is because as a kid in high school, you're like, wow, that's the dream job. But every some time you talk to these people, they're like, well, you got to understand. I'm playing the same level over and over and over again.
他们显然会带你去看那些测试游戏的人。这就是他们的工作。他们就像每天工作八个小时。他们只是像这样。然后这就有点搞笑，因为作为一个高中生，你会想，哇，那是梦想工作。但有时你和这些人交谈时，他们会说，嗯，你得明白。我在一遍又一遍地玩同一个关卡。
It's not like I'm playing the game and just like having fun. It's like, no, I'm doing it in this very odd way. Anyways, I have fond memories of going to the EA campus. And were you there just for some kind of like annual thing or just every once in a while work would necessitate you going out there? I don't remember why I visited Vancouver. I know that I did once. I don't remember what it was for us.
这不像是在玩游戏，只是觉得好玩。而是，不，我是以这种非常奇怪的方式在做这件事。不管怎样，我对去 EA 园区有着美好的回忆。你当时去那里只是为了某种年度活动，还是偶尔因为工作需要才去那里的？我不记得我为什么去参观温哥华了。我知道我去过一次。我不记得是为了什么了。
It was some get-together of engineers for some. something, I'm sure. But yeah, back then, that was where they did a bunch of sports titles, like you said, right? They did, was it FIFA there at the time? And was it Madden NFL? Yep, they definitely had FIFA. In fact, that's probably my, well, what are my fondest memories? I had a PS2. I convinced my parents to let me have a PS2 at the tail end of high school. And I had FIFA 2006. And I don't know what year they switched from the six or eight directional movements. So you're going to have to like give me the right terminology if you know it or help me
那肯定是工程师们的某次聚会。但我确信。不过，是的，在那个时候，那就是他们制作一系列体育游戏的地方，就像你说的，对吧？他们当时制作了，是 FIFA 吗？还有 Madden NFL 吗？是的，他们确实有 FIFA。事实上，那可能是我，嗯，我最美好的回忆是什么？我有一台 PS2。我在高中末期说服父母让我拥有了一台 PS2。我拥有《FIFA 2006》。我不知道他们是从哪一年开始从六方向或八方向移动切换的。所以如果你知道的话，你得告诉我正确的术语，或者帮帮我
where you can. But I remember in FIFA at a certain point and 2006 was one of them, you would move with like the little joystick and it had eight different directions. And so you could very precisely like choose when you wanted to switch what is that 45 degrees. But then at a certain point they switched to what was called like omnidirectional. And so they had like all like whatever degrees of the 360 degrees. thing. And that made it much more difficult because, like, I could be running straight and then I would just switch and I'd be going 45 degrees. And anyways, I have very fond memories of FIFA 2006.
能帮就帮。但我记得在某个时期的《FIFA》中，《FIFA 2006》就是其中之一，你可以用一个小摇杆移动，它有八个不同的方向。所以你可以非常精确地选择你想在什么时候切换那个，是多少度，45度？但后来在某个时候，他们切换到了所谓的“全方位移动”。所以他们拥有所有，不管多少度的 360 度。东西。这使得它变得困难得多，因为，比如，我可能正在直线奔跑，然后我一换方向，就会变成 45 度角。不管怎样，我对《FIFA 2006》有着非常美好的回忆。
And that was definitely back then an EA label. But I know now that they lost it and they have something called. Yeah. I don't know exactly. But yeah, they lost the FIFA. They had the FIFA license for years and years and then they lost it probably a while ago now. Yeah. Now there's something called, I know it was like pro evolution soccer PES at one point in time. So that was a different franchise. As far as I know, that wasn't EA. That was a sort of competitor when EA had FIFA. Yeah.
那在当时绝对是 EA 的王牌。但我现在知道他们失去了版权，他们有了一个叫什么来着。是的。我不太清楚。不过，是的，他们失去了 FIFA。他们拥有 FIFA 的版权很多很多年，然后可能在不久前失去了它。是的。现在有什么东西叫，我知道有段时间叫《实况足球》（PES）。所以那是另一个系列。据我所知，那不是 EA。那是 EA 拥有 FIFA 时的一个竞争对手。是的。
So now they, now I can't, anyways, I don't really, I haven't, I never game seriously. But I had a PS2 at one point and I had an Xbox something at one point. And I've played a bit of computer games. But anyway, so you used to work at EA and then you worked at, was it Blizzard from there? I worked at EA in the UK for a while. That was where I started. Well, Bullfrog was the studio. But when I joined there in mid-95, it was already a wholly owned subsidiary of EA.
所以现在他们，现在我不能，不管怎样，我真的不，我从来不严肃地玩游戏。但我曾经有一台 PS2，某个时候有一台 Xbox 什么的。我也玩过一点电脑游戏。不过不管怎样，你曾经在 EA 工作，然后你从那里去了，是暴雪吗？我在英国的 EA 工作过一段时间。那是我开始的地方。嗯，Bullfrog 是那个工作室。但当我于 95 年年中加入时，它已经是 EA 的全资子公司了。
And over the next five, six years, you know, EA started to manage more and more. Then I worked for a company, a little British company called Kooju for a couple of years. back in the day they did a few things they did Microsoft train simulator I think okay those those games are actually huge driving simulators and flight simulators they're yeah oh yeah the rigs that you can see on
在接下来的五六年里，你知道的，EA 开始进行越来越多的管理。然后我为一家名为 Kooju 的英国小公司工作了几年。过去他们做过一些事情，他们做过《微软模拟火车》，我想，好吧。那些游戏实际上是巨大的驾驶模拟器和飞行模拟器，它们是，哦，是的，你在
Instagram that people set up they get home from their driving job and then they go drive more well I put in my hours on things like Euro truck simulator it's it's highly addictive even though you'd think like what you know you're just driving around but it's like
Instagram 上可以看到人们设置的那些模拟驾驶舱，他们从驾驶工作下班回家，然后去开更多的车。嗯，我在《欧洲卡车模拟》之类的事情上投入了我的时间，它太让人上瘾了，尽管你可能会想，什么，你知道的，你只是在开车，但它就像是
I don't know it's a very addictive of a type of game. Yeah, yeah, it can be. Then I moved to EA, Los Angeles. Worked there for, I don't know, five years. Yeah, about five years. Then I moved to Blizzard. I worked for Blizzard for pretty much 10 years.
我不知道，这是一种非常容易上瘾的游戏类型。是的，是的，确实如此。然后我搬到了 EA 洛杉矶。在那里工作了，我不知道，五年吧。是的，大约五年。然后我去了暴雪。我在暴雪工作了差不多 10 年。
And then I left the games industry. So, yeah, I mean, we're talking about golf games. Should we talk about your other types of favorite games? I mean, Bryce every once in a while mentions his mud, whatever things. And I always think, man, that's the only game you ever bring up. is your mud thing well you know yeah I played a mud in college
然后我离开了游戏行业。所以，是的，我的意思是，我们在谈论高尔夫游戏。我们该聊聊你喜欢的其他类型的游戏吗？我的意思是，布莱斯偶尔会提到他的 MUD（多用户地牢）之类的东西。我总是想，天哪，那是你唯一会提起的游戏。就是你的 MUD 东西。嗯，你知道的，是的，我在大学里玩过 MUD
of course like many of us did I like a bunch of different games you know funnily enough I've seldom worked on games that I normally played at the time but like I said I'm not a fan of golf in real life but golf video games are strangely compelling interesting
当然，就像我们许多人做的那样。我喜欢各种各样的游戏，你知道的，说来有趣，我很少参与制作我当时经常玩的游戏。但就像我说的，我在现实生活中不是高尔夫球迷，但高尔夫电子游戏却有着奇怪的吸引力，很有趣。
but you know games games are interesting because they you know to bring it to the topic of the podcast maybe working in games games is interesting because there are all kinds of things that go into programming a game. You know, there are lots and lots of different aspects. There are lots of, you're not just working in one place, or at least if you're in a big studio, there are lots of different kinds of engineers who specialize in maybe different things. You know, there's, to just run through
但你知道的，游戏，游戏很有趣，因为它们，你知道的，为了切入播客的主题，也许在游戏行业工作，在游戏里工作很有趣，因为编程一部游戏需要涉及各种各样的事情。你知道的，有非常非常多的不同方面。有很多方面，你不仅是在一个地方工作，或者至少如果你在一个大工作室里，会有很多不同种类的工程师，他们可能专精于不同的事情。你知道的，有，仅仅从
a very small sample, there's specialization in, well, graphics is obviously one, and that subdivides. animation is sort of a separate subfield of that. Networking, physics, AI, AI as it's called in games, gameplay, UI, audio, you know, I could go on and on. But there are lots of specializations available and lots of different problems, lots of interesting problems, you know. I spent most of my career as a, one of my specialities was network programming. Is that what you spent across the different companies that you worked at? That's typically what you were working on? A lot of the time, yes, especially in my early career. It was sort of lucky that the first game I worked on, they said, hey, we need someone to do the networking and I worked on it. And of course,
一个非常小的样本来看，专精领域有，嗯，图形学显然是一个，而且这还可以细分。动画某种程度上是其中的一个独立子领域。网络、物理、AI（在游戏里通常就叫AI）、玩法、UI、音频，你知道的，我可以一直说下去。但有非常多的专业方向可供选择，有非常多的不同问题，很多有趣的问题，你知道的。我职业生涯的大部分时间都在，我的专业领域之一是网络编程。这就是你在你工作过的不同公司里所做的事情吗？这通常是你一直在做的工作吗？很多时候是的，尤其是在我的职业生涯早期。有点幸运的是，我参与的第一款游戏，他们说，嘿，我们需要有人来做网络，然后我就去做了。当然，
once you've done it once, then the next title, you kind of have the experience, so you get picked again. And it turned out that, of course, and this was back in like 1995, Bullfrog was a pretty forward-looking company because they did make their games to be multiplayer. And then, of course, when the internet came along and people got internet at home and it took off massively, then every game basically became a network game and it became sort of very good for my career that I was experienced in that. I mean, yeah, I mean, where should we take? I feel like I should just like, because I have very little experience or, you know, some
一旦你做过一次，那么在下一部作品中，你就有了一定的经验，所以你再次被选中了。事实证明，当然，这回到了 1995 年左右，Bullfrog 是一家相当有远见的公司，因为他们确实将游戏制作成了多人游戏。然后，当然，随着互联网的兴起，人们在家里用上了互联网并大规模普及，然后基本上每一款游戏都变成了网络游戏，而我有这方面的经验，这对我的职业生涯来说变得非常好。我的意思是，是的，我的意思是，我们应该把话题带到哪里？我觉得我应该，因为我只有很少的经验，或者，你知道的，有些
might say zero experience when it comes to the games industry. So I don't even know necessarily what are the right questions to ask here. But like, well, first I'll pause. Are there things that, you know, if you want to guide this, conversation. Maybe we'll just start there. We could talk about, we could talk about how different hard. The other thing about the games industry is like the hardware has been changing continually and a lot, you know, whether it's the console cycle or PC upgrades for a while, for the last three decades at least. Plus. But you know, as far as, as like algorithms or, you know,
可以说对游戏行业完全零经验。所以我甚至不知道在这里该问什么样的问题。不过，首先我停一下。有什么是，你知道的，如果你想引导这个对话的话。也许我们就从这里开始。我们可以谈谈，我们可以谈谈不同的硬件有多难。游戏行业的另一个特点是硬件一直在不断地变化，而且变化很大，你知道的，无论是主机世代还是电脑升级，在过去一段时间里，至少在过去的三十年里。还有。但你知道，至于算法或者，你知道的，
or things like that that actually make a game work. Again, there are lots of things under the hood. You know, for example, path-finding algorithms, algorithms for just arranging the world, you know, algorithms for, and data structures for representing the world, whether it be three-dimensional or two-dimensional or what have you, for doing collision and physics.
或者类似的东西，真正让游戏运行起来的东西。同样的，幕后有很多东西。你知道，比如，寻路算法，用来安排游戏世界的算法，你知道的，用于表示游戏世界的算法和数据结构，无论是三维的还是二维的或者别的什么，用于处理碰撞和物理效果。
You know, and then there's, like I was saying, all those specialities, like audio programs, for games is it whole whole whole whole whole whole speciality and that's sort of very very sort of low level concerns you know because the human eye is really really forgiving you know you can that's why television works at such a pitifully low frame rate right you can watch something at 30 frames a second like a more a movie at 24 frames a second historically right and your eyes just fine with that you you don't think there's anything wrong i was watching something last night and it was I don't know what you call it, but like stuttering a bit.
你知道的，然后就像我刚才说的，所有这些专业领域，比如游戏的音频程序，这是一个非常非常非常非常庞大的专业领域，这属于非常非常底层的关注点，你知道的，因为人眼其实真的非常宽容，你知道的，你可以，这就是为什么电视能以如此可怜的低帧率工作，对吧，你可以看一个每秒30帧的东西，比如历史上每秒24帧的电影，对吧，你的眼睛对那完全没问题，你不会觉得有什么不对劲，我昨晚在看一个东西，它有点，我不知道你怎么称呼它，但有点卡顿。
Like, I swear to God, the frame rate was like speeding up and slowing down. Admittedly, we were running this on a 15-year-old MacBook Pro. This MacBook Pro has got to go. It's, you know, it's losing Wi-Fi. It's got a bunch of issues. But, like, I was like, do you notice that? I was asking him my wife. I was like, do you notice that?
就像，我发誓，帧率一会儿变快一会儿变慢。诚实地说，我们是在一台用了15年的MacBook Pro上运行它的。这台MacBook Pro该换了。它，你知道的，Wi-Fi连接不稳。它有一堆毛病。但是，我就像，你注意到了吗？我问我妻子。我说，你注意到了吗？
And she's like, notice what? And I was like, it kind of seems like it's, I don't know, the frame rate seems messed up. She's like, looks fine to me. And, I mean, that proves your point. Maybe I'm hallucinating stuff. Yeah, and certainly you can sort of tell the difference between, you know, 30 FPS and 60 FPS and higher. But in general, my point is that, you know, the human eye is way, way more forgiving than the ear. Yeah, that is true.
她说，注意到什么？我说，感觉好像是，我不知道，帧率好像出问题了。她说，我觉得挺正常的。我的意思是，这证明了你的观点。也许是我产生幻觉了。是的，当然你可以分辨出，你知道的，30帧和60帧以及更高帧率的区别。但总的来说，我的观点是，你知道的，人眼比耳朵要宽容得多。是的，确实如此。
You can hear glitches that are absolutely, you know, minuscule compared to what your eye would tolerate. So audio programming is a special kind of real-time sensitive domain. Yeah, that, I mean, Timor, he works in the audio space, right? Yeah, he's done a lot of audio programming in his career. Yeah, I know, I think he's currently the co-host of CPPCast, right? That podcast. I think you have Matt Rappair. Oh, that's right.
你可以听到绝对可以说是微不足道的杂音，而你的眼睛却能包容。所以音频编程是一种非常特殊的实时敏感领域。是的，我是说，蒂莫尔（Timor），他在音频领域工作，对吧？是的，他的职业生涯中做过很多音频编程。是的，我知道，我想他目前是CPPCast的联合主持人，对吧？那个播客。我想你有马特·拉佩尔（Matt Rappair）。哦，对的。
Well, so wait, who are the current hosts? Matt and Jason. Jason came back. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Timor and Phil were hosting it for a while. That's what you're doing. Yeah, yeah, well, because it's gone through.
好吧，等等，谁是目前的主持人？马特和杰森。杰森回来了。是的。嗯哼。蒂莫尔和菲尔曾经主持过一段时间。这就是你在做的。是的，是的，因为经历过。
Were they the second? set of hosts? So Rob started it. Jason joined him at like episode three or something. So they were the first set. And then it went on the hayt us after Rob and Jason retired for a while.
他们是第二批主持人吗？罗布（Rob）创办了它。杰森在大约第三期左右加入了进来。所以他们是第一批。然后在罗布和杰森退休后，它停播了一段时间。
And then Phil and Timor picked it up. And then they were doing it for a while. I think they were, I think they'd come to a point but they weren't doing it regularly anymore. And then Jason picked it back up and Matt joined him. Right, right.
然后菲尔和蒂莫尔接手了。他们做了一段时间。我想他们，我想他们到了一个不再定期制作的阶段。然后杰森重新接手，马特加入了进来。对，对。
So now we're on three editions. And technically, yeah, Phil has been on like four different, because I've listened to all of them. He's been on four different podcasts. There was CPP chat. He was on CPPCAST. He also had no diagnostic required.
所以现在我们有三个版本。而且严格来说，是的，菲尔参与过大约四个不同的，因为我听了所有这些。他参加过四个不同的播客。曾有CPP chat。他参加过CPPCCAST。他还做过“无需诊断”（no diagnostic required）。
And I swear he has like another fourth podcast out there. NDR. You never listen to that one? No, no. The podcast world is so saturated. I don't have time to listen to everything. Yeah, that's true. I think there was only like 10 episodes or something.
我发誓他还有第四个播客。NDR。你从来没听过那个吗？没有，没有。播客世界太饱和了。我没有时间听所有东西。是的，确实如此。我想大概只有10集左右吧。
It was fleeting in its existence. Anyways, you were saying that audio is much less forgiving than video. because yeah anytime you ever hear any kind of hiccup or you're like it it's it's literally jarring it can like ruin yeah you you hear clicks and pops yeah that might last last only you know a matter of microseconds yeah and you're able to hear that but your eye your eye is fine with you know pretending like it's fluid motion when you're only seeing 30 images a second something yeah i wonder what the i'm not sure if we if we know the answer that question. Why is that? Is it? Are I, like, processing, video, like your brain's image processing
它的存在十分短暂。不管怎样，你刚才说音频比视频宽容得多，因为是的，任何时候只要你听到任何种类的卡顿，你就会觉得，这简直太刺耳了，它会毁了，是的，你会听到咔哒声和爆音，是的，它们可能只持续了，你知道的，几微秒，是的，你能够听到那个，但你的眼睛，你的眼睛完全可以假装它是流畅的运动，即使你每秒只看到30幅图像，某种程度上，是的，我在想，我不确定我们是否知道那个问题的答案。为什么会这样？是吗？我们的眼睛，比如，处理视频，就像你大脑的图像处理
is much less equipped than, like, audio, and therefore it can only take in so much, whereas the... Maybe. I don't know. We'd have to ask... Some biologist or neuroscientist. Maybe an evolutionary biologist slash neuroscientist, yes. Anyway, so, I mean, so you spent most of your time in the networking space, but there's all these different algorithms within games programming, and correct me if I'm wrong, you were doing C++ plus basically the entire time, correct? Yes, yeah. Although later in my career, you know, my career in games really finished before,
能力远不如音频那样装备精良，因此它只能接受那么多，而...也许吧。我不知道。我们得去问...某个生物学家或神经科学家。也许是个进化生物学家兼神经科学家，是的。无论如何，我的意思是，所以你把大部分时间花在了网络领域，但游戏编程中有各种各样的算法，如果我没记错的话，你基本上整个过程都在用C++，对吧？是的，是的。尽管在我职业生涯的后期，你知道的，我在游戏行业的职业生涯实际上在...
I would say before the large-scale commoditization of engines, right? Or just when that was coming about. So in other words, we had Unreal, we had Unity, but there was still a lot of, and especially at Blizzard, there was still a lot of in-house engine work, right? And so in particular, I'm thinking of Unity, which basically means that games are written in C-sharp now, if you're using Unity a lot of the time. But, you know, there's still a lot of C++ that goes on in the performance-ensitive parts, in graphics, I think, in various parts of games. But yes, and I, and I, although you say I did networking for most of my career, it's more true to say that I divert the speciality in networking.
可以说是在引擎大规模商品化之前结束的？或者说正当那个时期到来的时候。换句话说，我们有了虚幻引擎（Unreal），我们有了Unity，但仍然有很多，特别是在暴雪（Blizzard），仍然有很多内部引擎的工作，对吧？所以我特别想到了Unity，这基本上意味着如果你经常使用Unity的话，现在的游戏都是用C#编写的。但是，你知道的，在性能敏感的部分，在图形学中，我认为在游戏的各个部分，仍然有大量的C++在运行。但是是的，我，而且我，尽管你说我职业生涯的大部分时间都在做网络，但更准确的说法是我专攻网络领域。
Later in my career, I moved more into a lead programmer role where I was sort of doing everything. And by the time I'd spent 20 plus years in the industry, I'd done most of the programming jobs that are in games. Was there any part of that stack of work that you found the most interesting or rewarding to work on? Or they all have their different pros and maybe all pros, no cons or pros and cons? You know, they're all, I just liked, I've always just liked programming, making things work, building things. The good feeling you get when something is working well like it should. And, you know, in games, that feeling is available because you have a very direct measure of what working well means. It means fitting in the frame time.
在职业生涯的后期，我更多地转到了主程序员的角色，基本上什么都做。当我在这个行业度过了20多年后，我做过游戏里的大部分编程工作。在所有这些工作内容中，你发现哪一部分最有趣或最有成就感？还是说它们各有各的优点，也许全都是优点没有缺点，或者各有利弊？你知道的，它们全都是，我只是喜欢，我一直都只是喜欢编程，让事情运转起来，构建东西。当事情像应有的那样顺利运转时，你就会获得那种美妙的感觉。而且，你知道的，在游戏里，这种感觉是很容易获得的，因为你对“运转良好”有着非常直接的衡量标准。这意味着它符合帧时间。
You know, it means it means not having any visible artifacts. And a lot of times, yeah, it means so there's a lot of kind of optimization that occurs to make sure, you know, because because you're trying to run what is supposed to be a real time simulation many times or present that illusion, right? And there are things you have to do and you have to fit within the 16.6 milliseconds. or whatever it is, you know. The frame time, back in the day, it used to be 60 hertz. These days, consoles can run at variable frame rates above 60, you know. And so it's almost like in the old days, it was very much, actually, in the bad old days, you might say, it was just, you know,
你知道的，这意味着它意味着没有任何可见的瑕疵。很多时候，是的，这意味着会有很多优化，以确保，你知道的，因为你试图运行的往往是一个实时模拟很多次，或者呈现出那种错觉，对吧？有些事情你必须去做，你必须在16.6毫秒之内完成，或者不管具体是多少时间，你知道的。帧时间，在过去，通常是60赫兹。如今，主机可以以高于60的各种帧率运行，你知道的。所以这几乎就像在过去的日子里，实际上，在糟糕的旧时代，你可能会说，这只是，你知道的，
very much kind of lockstep rendering and simulation. But, you know, over the years, as hardware got more powerful, as systems got more decoupled, and as we got a, better handle on things. Now, you know, you don't, or I should say now, I mean for the last 20 years, probably when I say now, you know, you don't, you don't run everything at the fixed cadence. You run things at variable cadences and the touch points where they intersect are well defined, you know, so you, for instance, you don't run, you know, take a very, very simple example. If you're running some kind of AI, say path finding, right, you don't, you don't need to be necessarily,
非常死板的渲染和模拟。但是，你知道的，多年来，随着硬件变得更强大，系统变得更加解耦，我们对事情有了更好的掌握。现在，你知道的，你不用，或者我应该说现在，我的意思是过去20年里，当我提到现在时，你知道的，你不用，你不用以固定的节奏运行一切。你以不同的节奏运行事物，它们相交的切入点是被明确定义的，你知道的，所以，举个例子，你不用，举个非常非常简单的例子。如果你在运行某种人工智能，比如寻路算法，对吧，你不需要，不一定需要，
or enemy smarts, enemy AI, right? You don't need to be updating that every, every frame, right? You run that on a typically on a much lower cadence than the rendering, right? The other thing to know is going back to realism, you know, I think, I think, like we were saying, sports games were one of the few genres that were absolutely pushing the realism. FPS to some extent in rendering was pushing realism. But, you know, very early on in my career, I was disabreact. of the notion that games are about making things try to be real.
或者敌人的智能，敌人的人工智能，对吧？你不需要每一帧都去更新它，对吧？你运行它的频率通常比渲染要低得多，对吧？另一件需要知道的事情是，回到现实主义上来，你知道的，我认为，就像我们刚才说的，体育游戏是极少数绝对在推动现实主义极限的流派之一。第一人称射击游戏（FPS）在渲染方面也在一定程度上推动了现实主义。但是，你知道的，在我职业生涯的早期，我就被破除了一个迷信，即游戏就是为了让事物尽量真实。
They're not about realism. They're about fun. They're about smoke and mirrors a lot of the time. Yeah, like I said, I'm not a big gamer, but I do watch. I've mentioned it on the YouTube or on the podcast, the guy named Dunkie, I don't know, videos. He's like a, I don't know what you call him, YouTube video game comedian. He makes these little 10-minute videos where he reviews video games, but just kind of with, like, comedic banter. and so I've seen a bunch of like different games just because I watch this guy's YouTube channel
它们不是为了追求现实主义。它们是为了好玩。它们很多时候靠的是虚张声势和障眼法。是的，就像我说的，我不是一个大玩家，但我确实看。我已经在YouTube上或者在播客里提过了，有个叫Dunkie的家伙，我不知道，他的视频。他就像一个，我不知道你怎么称呼他，YouTube电子游戏喜剧演员。他制作这些短短10分钟的视频，在视频里他评测电子游戏，但带有某种喜剧式的玩笑。所以我看过很多不同的游戏，只是因为我看了这个家伙的YouTube频道
and a lot of times these more recent ones like this is so sad because I'm not going to remember any of the names of them but like you're right they don't they almost are going for like this kind of like I don't know if hyper realistic or surreal like look where the grass is like clearly it's flowing in the wind and like the physics engine's really good and it looks really nice but it is not at all like it doesn't actually look like a field of grass but like I've seen a lot of these more recent games
而且很多时候这些比较新的游戏——这太悲哀了，因为我记不住它们的名字——但就像你说的那样，它们不是。它们几乎在追求一种，我不知道这是不是超真实或者超现实的视觉效果，比如草地明显在风中飘拂，物理引擎真的很好，看起来真的很不错，但它一点也不像，它实际上看起来不像是草地，但我看过很多这些更新的游戏
that kind of have one of them was done by Jonathan Blow too it was the his not his most recent one that he's releasing right now but the last one that was like a kind of puzzle game but it was on this island and the water looks really nice and like
其中有一款也是乔纳森·布洛（Jonathan Blow）制作的，那不是他现在正在发布的最新作品，而是上一款，有点像解密游戏，在一个小岛上，水看起来非常不错，而且
it looks beautiful but it doesn't... Witness are you talking about witness witness yes yes yes I don't know how I ended up, did you ever play witness? Yes, I played through witness, yes. Okay, so I mean we're going to have an interesting discussion about witness. I ended up on a deep rabbit hole. I don't exactly know how.
它看起来很美，但它不...你说的是《见证者》（The Witness）吗？《见证者》，是的，是的。我不知道我是怎么落入这个圈套的，你玩过《见证者》吗？是的，我通关了《见证者》，是的。好吧，我的意思是，我们将对《见证者》展开有趣的讨论。我陷入了一个深深的兔子洞。我不太清楚是怎么回事。
You know, sometimes you're just on YouTube, you click one video, you click another video. And I was watching a bunch. I watched this like one hour review of the game with a bunch of spoilers. And then I watched this other video. And then I watched like Jonathan Blow reacting to that guy's review saying that like people that don't have an understanding of game design, like shouldn't be reviewing. And anyways, the point, the point being, very interesting. Never played it.
你知道的，有时候你就在YouTube上，点了一个视频，又点另一个视频。我看了很多。我看了这个时长一小时的游戏评测，里面有很多剧透。然后我又看了另一个视频。然后我看了乔纳森·布洛对那个家伙评测的回应，他说那些对游戏设计没有理解的人不应该做评测。不管怎样，重点是，非常有趣。我从来没玩过。
I basically know the game, though, and it's got some very interesting aspects to it. And the point being, it's very beautiful. And like the water, you know, kind of has this, like realism to it. It looks very, you know, nice. Is there a word for that? As far as I remember, witness, isn't it, cell shaded? Cell shaded. You'll have to explain to both me and the listener.
不过我基本上了解这个游戏，它有一些非常有趣的方面。重点是，它非常漂亮。而且水，你知道的，有一种现实感。它看起来非常，你知道的，不错。这个有什么专门的词来形容吗？据我所记得，《见证者》，难道不是，赛璐珞渲染（cell-shaded）的吗？赛璐珞渲染。你得向我和听众解释一下。
It looks like a cartoon. cell. That's the rendering style. Yes. I mean, maybe that's what I've been trying to describe this whole time. Is that like, but the thing is, is that... Think of like, Legend of Zelda Wind Waker, if you know, that game. Yes, yes, yes, yes. That's a cell-shaded game, right? Okay, so this is the word I'm looking for is a lot of the games have this cell-shadedness,
它看起来像个动画片。赛璐珞（cell）。那是渲染风格。是的。我是说，也许这就是我这一整一直在试图描述的东西。就是那种，但问题是...想想《塞尔达传说：风之杖》（Legend of Zelda Wind Waker），如果你知道那个游戏的话。是的，是的，是的，是的。那是赛璐珞渲染的游戏，对吧？好吧，所以我一直在寻找的词就是，很多游戏都有这种赛璐珞渲染的风格，
or I guess it's just a, you just described it, it's cell-shaded. And some of it, like, you can see that, like, the physics of the grass and, like, the physics of the... Everything looks really smooth and really nice, but it doesn't look... real, but like the physics look real enough and whatnot. Anyways, and I've just seen a lot of games recently that, like, I don't know if this is a new style and it just became popular because for whatever reason, it's easier to render like smoothly than compared to like, I don't know, what's the cyberpunk 277, that one that had like,
或者我想这只是一种，你刚才已经描述过了，它就是赛璐珞渲染。其中的一部分，比如，你可以看到草的物理效果以及...一切看起来都非常流畅，非常不错，但它看起来并不真实，然而物理效果看起来又足够真实等等。无论如何，我最近看到很多游戏，像，我不知道这是一种新风格，而且它变得流行起来，无论出于什么原因，与比如说，我不知道，赛博朋克2077相比，那种需要，
you know, your GTX, et cetera. Maybe you can tell us about self-shading. If you know, like, you know, what are the... I mean, cell shading is just a style, right? it's a style produced by like a shader on the GPU it's just what you're saying I think is that and I agree the graphical style you know like we were saying it's not all about realism realism is one style of graphics
你知道的，你的GTX显卡等等，渲染起来更流畅一些。也许你可以跟我们讲讲赛璐珞渲染。如果你知道的话，你知道，有哪些...我是说赛璐珞渲染只是一种风格，对吧？这是一种由GPU上的着色器生成的风格，正如你所说，我认为，我也同意，图形风格，你知道的，正如我们所说，并不完全关乎现实主义，现实主义只是图形的一种风格
but the graphics that tend to the games that tend to go the distance the games that you go back to and still think look good 10 years later 20 years later are the ones that are properly art directed and usually did not try to go for realism because 20 years ago, we couldn't do realism like we could do today. It just doesn't, it looks great at the time, but when you go back, it doesn't look good, right? Yeah, interesting. And yeah, do you want to do a mini review? A mini review of The Witness? I mean, I think it's a great game that, you know, the Witness is interesting almost not for its graphics, but for the kind of game it is, which is an exploratory, discovery-driven game,
但是能够经受时间考验的图形，那些你过上10年、20年还会回去重温并觉得它依然好看的游戏，都是那些拥有恰当的美术指导、并且通常没有刻意追求现实主义的游戏，因为20年我们做不出今天这样的现实主义效果。它在当时看起来很棒，但当你回过头来看时，它就不好看了，对吧？是的，很有意思。是的，你想做一个迷你评测吗？对《见证者》的迷你评测？我的意思是，我认为这是一部极好的游戏，你知道的，《见证者》之所以有趣，几乎不是因为它的画面，而是因为它是一种什么类型的游戏，它是一个探索性的、由发现驱动的游戏，
right the great thing about the witnesses like you're you dropped on this island you don't know really what it's about what you're trying to do there are no enemies to kill nothing kind of classical kind of objective you just have to explore and figure out how to progress and that's it's a great kind of discovery driven game in that way it's a puzzle game and at its heart right as as you find out by playing but yeah that that's what makes the witness good I mean, I was entertained just watching the video of people playing it. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com, for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion
对吧，《见证者》最棒的地方在于，你被扔到这个岛上，你其实并不清楚它是关于什么的，你在那里究竟要干什么，没有敌人要杀，没有什么那种传统的经典目标，你只需要探索并弄清楚如何推进，这就是它的魅力所在，它是一个极好的由发现驱动的游戏，从本质上讲，正如你在游玩过程中会发现的那样，但是的，这就是《见证者》优秀的原因。我是说，光是看着别人玩游戏的视频我都觉得很有意思。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在ADSP thepodcast.com上，里面有我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论区的链接
where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brice. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在那里留下你的想法、评论和问题。谢谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反布莱斯（anti-brice）。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。